when it comes to the creative process
there's a method to the madness of
avengers endgame co-directors Joe and
Anthony Russo during a reddit ask me
anything session the ace filmmakers
responded to a fan who asked why one of
the flicks more famous deleted scenes in
which all of the assembled heroes take a
knee out of respect after Tony Stark's
heroic act of self-sacrifice wasn't
included in the final cut of the film in
case you haven't gotten a chance to
catch the exercise scene here's a brief
explanation you're a cooler Stark
mortally injured himself for using the
Infinity stones to snap Thanos and his
invading armies out of existence and
able to even speak he held on long
enough for Peter Parker to tell him that
the Avengers had won and Finn's wife
Pepper Potts to reassure him that she
and his daughter Morgan would be okay
without him he can raise him and so he
did rest taking his last breath the
deleted scene in question would have
taken place directly after this in it we
first see an utterly shell-shocked
Captain America and Thor in disbelief
over the loss then we cut to Hawkeye
who's slowly tentatively drops to one
knee one by one the rest of the heroes
follow suit first to charla then Captain
Marvel followed by Peter quill nebula
Valkyrie ant-man cap and Doctor Strange
as the camera pulls out to a white shots
we see that everybody is kneeling except
of course for 2014 Gamora who has taken
the opportunity to step away without
anyone noticing the scene is absolutely
fraught with emotion and would have fit
right in with a finished movie an idea
the Russos didn't disagree with
according to the directors the problem
was that as the scene played out they
noticed it was quite similar to another
scene which say a plan for the flicks
conclusion one that was just as epic and
which did make the final cut they
explained we found the Avengers kneeling
seat incredibly emotional but it felt
incredibly similar to the moments when
all of the heroes stood on the shore at
tony's funeral paying their respects to
him outside his home the two scenes one
in the film together
seemed to fight one another and created
a repetitious ending that actually makes
a ton of sense the way in which the
camera lingers on every character in a
deleted sequence making sure that
everyone's reaction is recorded strikes
pretty much the exact same emotional
chords as a funeral scene it could also
be argue that the few
scene is more impressive because it's
strikingly accomplished in a single shot
and because there are a few more
relevant parties present such as Nick
Fury happy Hogan and the grown-up Holly
kina if you're a coal he was the kid who
helped stock-outs during the events of
Iron Man 3 I would have added in the
retro retro reflective panels to make
him stealth mode I want a stealth man
Corey it's actually a good idea maybe
I'll build one it's easy to see how the
inclusion of the taken YZ scene could
have diluted the emotional impact of
that dramatic one take sequence it's
worth asking though if the scene might
show up in an alternate version of
endgame down the road a director's cut
perhaps it turns out that we have an
answer to that question as well thanks
for the Russos ama their answer to the
question of whether or not there will
ever be a director's cut event game was
straightforward
they said honestly no we have always
released a version of each of our movies
we wanted to so you would never see a
director's cut of a Russo brothers
Marvel movie because you have already
seen it we would have expected no less
the directing duo earn the trust of
Marvel Studios with their MCU effort
2014's Captain America the Winter
Soldier which is widely considered to be
one of the best movies the company has
produced they were then handed the task
of fielding three of the most complex
crossover films ever produced in Captain
America Civil War and the one-two punch
of Avengers infinity war and then the
game these guys obviously know what
they're doing and although they've said
that they're one with Marvel has pretty
much concluded it so happens that
they've also expressed interest in a
couple of properties which are now under
the studio's control the Fantastic Four
on the x-men after giving Marvel the
biggest movie of all time we're going to
go out on the limb and say that they
just might be down to work with these
two again check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]